72 seconds of logos WWE Studios because
we didn't just want to call it mirror
also we just didn't want to be confused
as a prequel to mirrors there's many
times I've had this dream it's never
been me before holding the gun now that
you've had this one dream we're ready to
let you out into society again and it
tells me that you haven't only overcome
your delusion in your conscious mind but
in his subconscious mind as well oh it's
gonna be one of those movies is it show
us a dream of something that might have
happened I have someone talking and in
mid-sentence switch to a completely
different scene make the audience wonder
where the hell they are for the entire
movie tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock
doctor who is that 16,000 16,000 on
skype who the fuck is skyping an auction
what an asshole family moves to a new
house in horror movie cliche damn they
got Amy Pond and Starbuck in this thing
they really went all out to try and get
an audience to this movie through
casting but not so much the actual
scares character looks at himself in a
mirror and decides to do a thin cliche
also I guess this isn't the only mirror
that's evil in this movie hi bye okay
great they found a way to put some
foreshadowing in the stream which means
the filmmakers have studied literary
devices and good for them but did they
read anything about cliches because this
scene is made up of 100% cliches also
you could have a drinking game of how
many times people get choked in this
movie the horror movie score and the
violent screaming is supposed to put me
on edge I guess but much like her fiance
I've been rudely awakened from a
peaceful sleep because I guess the first
some complaints about people printing
out their sales reports and finding some
really graphic crime-scene photos she
printed out crime-scene photos at her
job over a network this is a private
family matter right she's been obsessed
with this for years and would probably
have printed them out long ago in the
privacy of her own home
right the scene is completely
manufactured to show how this obsession
is affecting her relationships and
career right you must be
hangri this mirror eats people they
should have called this the mirror that
eats people and then change the entire
movie to fit that title because this
mirror for the entire movie doesn't eat
one person it might eat a dog but that
doesn't change the fact that this mirror
is hungry is a wasted idea also that
said what the fuck is this you must be
hungry line was that an idea that was in
the original draft and never got cut out
when they changed the movie to whatever
this is also I take issue with this
movie's definition of oculus anyway
an oculus is not a mirror it's an eye or
a circular opening in a dome the smear
never functions as an eye or a place
where vampires send their outcasts to be
burned by the Sun so I call bolt on this
title still hurts even if I 100%
believed in a demon illusion mirror
ghost thing and was obsessed with
killing it I would not believe the crack
in the physical mirror hurts it hi bye I
hear if you take the sheet off a
potential demon really slow it loses its
power to hurt you
ah Socrates the scene is like a roller
coaster only the car you're in
constantly goes up and straight and
never down ah George Washington you're
all sad this guy must have tiptoed in or
snuck back in like an asshole
remember when he left a couple minutes
ago yep those are average everyday
normal steps but they usually signal a
person walking toward you and prevent
jump scares like this alright dick can
you come by the house what's your
address no bee house I guess that's okay
with you then uh bye door closes before
we can figure out the mystery of how the
hell they got that huge mirror into a
station wagon those mirror demons offer
courtesy massage before killing a family
only apple products or a whole Apple
store can properly document this
paranormal activity this object is
responsible for at least 45 deaths in
the four centuries of its recorded
existence is that all also it seems
pretty unlikely that you were able to
figure out who owned this mirror over
the years and cross-reference it with a
bunch of grisly murders especially since
there are gaps in the timeline and no
one except you was made the connection
between the mirror and all the dying I
know this is silly to ask but you try
and call on the hour it's about seven
five that's not a silly request at all
woman I'm about to marry who has lots of
demons she won't discuss with me 17:55
Philip Lasser was found at her grand
fireplace okay so this goes on for a
couple minutes this is basically your
typical horror movie go to the library
or internet and research evil scene only
the main character already did the
research and it's a lot longer
alarm sounds because even the
screenwriters knew how long the scene
felt on the page also considering Kaylee
starts providing even more mirror
history after this protein bar break I
can't help but think the script went
four or five pages of mirror killings
until Karen Gilliam said damn can we
break this up a little more I need a
protein bar break and then a protein bar
break was written into the script
Shulman Capp 1955 skipped there's a huge
difference between causation and
correlation okay then in 2001 mom and
dad bought that new couch same year
grandpa had a heart attack
Robbie Schultz got hit by a car and our
cat ran away first off there's no way
you remember what year your parents
bought a damn couch especially when you
were eight years old second while this
fits the causation does not imply
correlation thing what are the chances
of 45 unusual murders happening around
this mirror over four centuries and
exchanging numerous hands slim I'm gonna
get slimmed the mirror only seems to
have power when it's not covered so why
not smash it when it's covered this is a
simple issue that goes unnoticed and
untried for the whole movie also come on
if someone really wanted to hurt this
mirror they're about a million tricks
you could do to destroy it without being
directly responsible so this you can't
destroy the mirror because it won't let
you she is nonsense one person I know I
was ever documented trying to break the
mirror Oliver Jeffries 1971 funny hiya
skipped over this dude during your
prologue a minute ago is it because you
were saving it just for this occasion
with a mirror hung at a central lecture
hall apparently the mirror only affected
one dude during the entire time it hung
there according to the students he stood
there quietly for almost a minute before
walking out of the hall and into traffic
and made it all the way to a bridge
before finally getting hit by a car
the mayor goes right there yeah but you
just told us that people try to destroy
the mirror before and some sort of evil
persuasion prevented them from doing it
so how would you be able to put the
mirror in the path of this anchor
without the mirror preventing you from
doing even that especially now that you
just showed the mirror how it works also
since this mirror specializes in the art
of Illusion even with alarms and
fail-safes you're going to start
experiencing delusions and won't know
what's real so this can only end badly
huh that's weird
this mirror likes to put people before
it kills them it's a strange motivation
but hey you've got to make the thankless
job of killing fun from time to time
finger nail horror hey guys come into my
office for a second all right what is
this okay I don't get it he saw one book
on the floor minute ago now there are
about 15 is that supposed to be scary
it's a who gives us kind of scary if
it's supposed to be the mirror creating
conflict between the dad and his kids
it's about the silliest way to do it I
don't know whether the dad unknowingly
added more books to the pile or the
mirror did it while he was gone and he
just didn't notice but this is the type
of scene where the biggest sin is that
no one could possibly give a fuck about
it Oliver Jeffries dad plans in the
classroom Tobin Capp dad class in the
bedroom what record keeps track of the
three dead plants no but I need you to
stay out of my office
80% of Rory Cochran's dialogue in this
movie is telling the kids to stay out of
the office Gardens Australian Shepherd
Tommen Capps Dalmatian the pets were
never found what the dovid cap had for
breakfast this morning
surely there's a document proving the
consumption of bacon and eggs with a
side of toast ear aw I saw mom lock him
in the office and I sat outside that
door all day and nobody went in around
have you ever heard of the fuzzy trace
theory of human psychology - all his
home are you sure about that because I'm
not Tim's rational explanation probably
beats demon mirror ghosts for
believability but the alternative is
that their dad was having an affair at
the house while the kids were home you
know the temperature in here is risen by
3 degrees who people in a small space
lights burning electrical equipment Tim
is right even though he's wrong I didn't
the temperature rise based on those
factors alone I should have skewed the
results a little bit dog has more sense
than any human characters in this movie
Jesus this took forever it took 24
minutes from the time Kaylee started
giving a history of the mirror for
something to actually happen during this
movies present day ah in this case being
right is not a good thing this is the
point where you just get the file if the
mirror can make you position cameras
without you knowing it and it surely
could make it
other things without knowing it and all
the alarms and fail seeps in the world
aren't going to prevent your death I
don't wanna be doing that yeah I know
it's time to get the hell out of there
you can't even be sure this is happening
right now I'll talk to you in an hour
fifty-fifty that was even Hammond
instead of investigating it further by
walking outside getting as far away from
the house as possible and calling
Michael Kaylee decides to be okay with
that possibly not being Michael even
though he's one of her fail-safes the
details of how Kaylee rested her mom's
attention from the seductive pull of the
mirror aren't important also burnt toast
shows that there's trouble in this
family but also shows there's even more
trouble with a simple toaster setting no
no when daddy's coming over I don't know
where he is
let me get this straight the dad was
seduced by a harlot in a mirror but
spent a lot of his time away from the
house did he know the mirror was evil
and gave it a good college try to not be
in the house or was this part of the
mirrors plan to support the cheating
narrative she wasn't in the office she
was on the stairs I think she went back
from the office I think she lives there
that's a really odd story with vague
details you told me there son but no
need to ask any more questions I guess
this is either too obvious or too dumb
for a cheating husband to leave around
in his office I'd be scared but I'm
still trying to figure out what's
actually happening in this movie the
mirror can create delusions and possess
people and for some reason it takes a
really long time with people before the
killing starts downtown - choking in
five four three two one
that demon-possessed mother does
everything in her power not to catch her
kids demon-possessed mother does
everything in her power not to break
down the door countdown - choking in
five four three oh that's not joking now
that's choking leave it to a man to do
the job right I guess yeah I have an
emergency with my wife look if the
mirrors sphere of influence reaches this
far into the house then the kid should
be possessed - unless it has morals
about children or something also at this
point the mirrors plan becomes
certifiably insane
even for a demon basically the mirror is
gonna tell Alan to change his wife in
the bedroom turn underwater mounts to a
wild animal
maybe that's scary I don't know what I
do know is that demons are brainstorming
ideas for screenplays and they actually
use people instead of pen and paper
Timm snap out of it movie will now blur
the line between past and present making
this more confusing but I have to stay
clear of that room in this movie it's my
absolute top priority as a father to ban
you from certain rooms in this house
next week on oculus the bathroom is
off-limits you are welcome to hang out
in here and play video games why aren't
you a homicidal maniac
why is your possessed form to be a weird
dick to your kids but the moms possessed
form is a choke app you psychopath what
the hell are the rules
eat the director said let's have your
characters eat apples it'll make them
look even more like assholes
Tim snap out of it Tim I guess she
eventually snapped him out of it with
the power of family the movie doesn't
explain Alan is a dick to his
demon-possessed wife the director said
let's have your character eat a light
bulb instead of an apple it'll make you
look like even more of an asshole and it
actually didn't happen now we're
assholes maybe we should say together
yeah and leave the house too that's
another good idea that I came up with
just now yeah this is freaky right here
this is the kind of thing that the movie
could have used more of instead it's a
subliminal freaky face and I have no
clue if the kid actually saw this around
or if the present is colliding with the
past or if it's just for the audience
huh mother is super quiet because of
obvious jump-scare possibilities
daughter has unhealthy obsession with
broken plates on the ground which leads
to this jump scare if you were startled
by this you have only yourself to blame
disobey me so now you get grounded what
kind of demon are you
you and your snot-nosed little brother
over there are not to step foot outside
of this house since you can't go
anywhere in the house either you'll have
to take the form of a gas so why didn't
you just chained up your kids while you
were at it she's you know using her
mother's illness to act out well if she
starts driving this is nothing ha ha
teens cries for help or just part of the
mystery of their growing minds and
bodies oh man Kaylie did this at the
worst possible moment during our dad's
daily fingernail removing time that'll
teach him I mean I have the power to do
far worse but this mine Fork is way more
fun
this is Exhibit A and the compelling you
can't win against a mirror that creates
delusions case also at this point
everything on the video is going to look
like either you or your brother did
these things on your own
how is this ever going to prove the
mirror is behind this
yeah can he see you right now I'm
guessing not but why put that thought in
my head
fix the whites the longest seduction
ever continues only 200 massages to go
before he's really not human anymore I
need police and an ambulance why don't
they ever walk further away from the
house okay so maybe they're still inside
the house and the mirror is giving them
the illusion that they're outside but it
seems like it would help them to try
especially since they have no idea
what's real as long as they're within
shouting distance of the house wash
ourselves good we're gonna have to get
really really brave Tim throws Kaylee's
words back at the main villain of the
movie oh wait why the fuck would you go
back in also this type of to happen in
the past I didn't seem to be any of this
mind-bending alternate reality stuff
going on when the mirror possessed their
parents plate grieving 'z I'm gonna let
you go for some reason if anyone asked
why good behavior Taylor Seagal movie
please the pronoun game so I have to ask
who the fuck he means you mean your dad
the one that's dead are you talking
about mom can't ever quite run down the
kid can she and thwarted by a door again
are you telling me she has all the
viciousness of a wild dog but still has
the motherly instinct not to break down
doors around the house the horror
choking in five four oh whatever who
cares why don't the kids get possessed
while trying to destroy the mural that's
what happened to their mom Kaylee's
throat must be shaped like Bart
Simpson's by now the kids can hear this
or are they imagining themselves as kids
now or have they been the whole time I
wish I knew this could have been badass
if it had a center of reality we could
hold on to instead we're just sitting
here guessing the whole time and
anything can happen and it loses real
suspense way up Kaylee's dead but
shouldn't the mirror be dead too that's
a heavy-ass anchor there it should have
gone through Kaylie and into the glass
all that strangling made her throat
really strong hey man if they didn't
believe you when you were a kid they're
definitely not gonna believe you wasn't
at all you might as well tell him Oh Jay
Simpson did it
you
yeah man you didn't know that this
country is founded it was founded by
people who were in the aliens man George
Washington man who's in a cult and the
cult was an aliens man and it's not your
fault it's not your fault
it's not your fault
mom mom mom mom mommy mommy mommy mama
mama-mama ma-ma-ma-ma-ma
mom mom mom
mommy mommy mama mama mama what go go on
without me just a cup soldier never
leaves a man behind huh it's a trick get
an axe